ideas spread for lots of reasons it
might be a catchy tune or a funny joke
that you've heard that sticks in the
brain and makes you want to propagate it
to tell others but one reason that we
know that idea stick and spread is
because they're useful the useful ones
propagate so an example is the wheel the
wheel wasn't invented in Egypt but it
was improved upon hundreds of years
later in Sumeria by going from a solid
disc to spokes how did it get to Sumeria
well merchants used it to travel and
spread their goods from point A to point
B so that utility to them the fact that
it was a useful invention helped the
invention itself spread from place to
place it was carried by humans to other
places where then it was improved upon
by other people a very important factor
is that there's an evolution happening
of ideas lots of ideas are tried lots of
ideas are proposed many of them don't
work out whatever reason they're not
true or they're not a good innovation
but then ideas pop up that do pass sort
of the Darwinian fitness test if you
will and they go on to thrive and they
spread and then they meet other ideas
and those ideas combine Matt Ridley
talks about that as idea sex when two
ideas meet and then they can give birth
to new ideas any technique that develops
new diversity of ideas helps that
Darwinian evolution
so Thomas Edison for example
experimented with thousands of different
filaments for the light bulb before he
got to one that worked that's another
way that Darwinian evolution can happen
lots of creation of diversity and then a
filter that picks just the ones that
people want to pass on for whatever
reason so this process of innovation of
spreading ideas from person to person
one of the things we've been doing some
of the ideas we've been creating are
accelerators of that process when we
invented a writing maybe five to seven
thousand years ago that accelerated the
spread of ideas when we went from
writing on Scrolls to the printing press
that could print things thousands of
times faster than monks could transcribe
them by hand that accelerated the spread
of ideas and helped launch the
Scientific Revolution and helped
accelerate the Renaissance and now with
the internet ideas can spread very very
rapidly funny cat pictures of course
utilize that but so do scientific papers
so do dialogue between researchers or
scholars in all sorts of fields so
everything we're doing in society both
increasing the number of people who are
educated giving them access to more
tools to do their research and giving
them more ways to communicate more
quickly is all accelerating this process
of Darwinian evolution of ideas